hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
taten welt ich habe heute nur ein ganz
kleines rezept für euch nämlich viel
mehr um etwas anderes gehen und zwar
haben wir zusammen ganz viele feste
gefeiert werden weihnachten gefeiert
ostern muttertag silvester und ihr wisst
ja wahrscheinlich dass jetzt gerade die
ramadan zeit ist seit zwei tagen
und diese zeit möchte ich einfach oder
dieses video möchte ich jetzt einfach
nutzen um so ein bisschen darüber zu
sprechen und es ist bei uns gerade in
deutschland so dass wir probleme haben
wir haben probleme wie welche
küchenmaschine kauf ich wieso geht der
hefeteig nicht auf wieso kommt der bus
zu spät
aber im prinzip sind ist eigentlich nur
luxus probleme weil auf der welt gibt es
wirklich wirkliche probleme
es gibt kinder die hungern müssen die
blätter von den bäumen essen müssen weil
sie wirklich nichts zu essen haben
es gibt immer noch krieg auf der welt es
gibt einfach sehr viel elend und viel
hunger und was machen wir wenn wir
hunger haben wir gehen einfach an
unseren kühlschrank oder andere
vorratskammer wir machen den kühlschrank
auf schau rein holen uns irgendwas raus
bei uns gibt's immer was wenn wir durst
haben nehmen wir uns die wasserflasche
oder gehen an den wasserhahn und genau
das soll man ja am ramadan wieder zu
schätzen wissen
indem man eben von sonnenaufgang bis
sonnenuntergang nichts ist und genau
darum soll es gehen muss man einfach mal
merken wie es ist hunger zu haben wir
sollen nicht am ramadan verhungern
das wird bei uns sowieso nicht passieren
sondern man soll einfach mal das gefühl
haben ich meine dann haben wir das
überhaupt mal wenn wir so ein ansatz von
hunger verspüren gehen wir sofort und
essen was oder holen uns was bestellen
uns was und so richtig dieses
hungergefühl zu haben mal auf diesen
bauchschmerz zu haben und dass es einem
einfach nicht mehr gut geht dass es das
soll man echt mal wieder spüren und zur
elternzeit
ich lese auch viel in foren
internetforen und ich sehe auch immer
ganz auf dass es immer schnell religiös
wert und die menschen dann doch wieder
miteinander streiten und dabei geht eben
nicht nur darum dieses hungergefühl auch
mal zu haben sondern auch mal persönlich
zu sein enthaltsam zu leben und das
finde ich sollte man jetzt einfach mal
wieder dran denken und sich mal wieder
bewusst machen und auch sodann leben
nino zu ramadan
sondern auch an allen 365 tagen im jahr
und geradezu ramadan zeit beim fasten
oder überhaupt beim fasten ist es
wichtig dass ihr euch gesund ernährt und
dass sie auf die lebensmittel achtet die
ihr zu euch nehmt denn sonst kann es
ganz schnell passieren dass ihr
kreislaufprobleme bekommt kopfschmerzen
bekommt ihr gar nicht auf gar nichts
mehr lust habt und es sollte nicht
passieren und ich sollte gerade in
dieser zeit sehr auf die gesundheit
achten
ich habe jetzt einfach mal zehn tipps
für euch wie ihr euch am ramadan
ernähren könnte wir wie gesund ihr euch
erhöhen könnte und dann sind diese 30
tage wirklich auch eine schöne zeit weil
man einfach mal sich und seinen körper
wirklich besser kennenlernt und hier
geht nicht darum dass ich euch jetzt
tipps gebe wie ihr den ganzen tag über
kein hunger und keinen durst bekommt
denn das faultier bekommen das sollte er
spüren sondern es geht einfach darum wie
ihr diese zeit gesund übersteht weil ich
bekomme echt viele e mails in denen und
stets ali
was kann ich tun damit ich keinen hunger
ich meine das ist ja normal ihr bekommt
hunger das sind 18 oder fast 19 stunden
an denen man fastet und nichts ist und
nichts trinkt und das müsst ihr
natürlich morgens vor dem fasten und
abends danach eben wieder ausgleichen so
dass einfach alles gesund überstanden
wird
tipp nummer eins ist ihr müsst viel
trinken das ist auch der wichtigste tipp
das heißt bevor ihr fastet und nachdem
ihr gewartet habt müsst ihr es da viel
trinken am besten wasser und da sollt
ihr auch wirklich genug trinken damit
ewig den ganzen tag über praktisch euren
körper damit versorgt habt und eben
ausreichend flüssigkeit im körper
vorhanden ist
mein tipp nummer 2 verzichtet auf kaffee
und schwarztee
denn die beiden in zehn eurem körper die
flüssigkeit wieder ihr bekommt sehr viel
durst weil einfach der körper dehydriert
deswegen solltet ihr gerade an ramadan
oder zur fastenzeit eben auf kaffee und
schwarztee möglichst verzichten
tipp nummer 3 verzichtet morgens bitte
auf süßigkeiten
denn bei süßigkeiten ist es so wenn ihr
die erst dann wird ihr blutzuckerspiegel
schnell hoch und geht aber dann auch
rasch wieder runter das heißt wenn ihr
morgens war einfach lust drauf habt
etwas süßes es vor allen dingen
süßigkeiten mit viel zucker
dann geht der blutzuckerspiegel hoch und
wenn ihr dann bereits am fastenzeit und
nichts mehr es geht der
blutzuckerspiegel wieder runter ich
fühle
total schlecht ihr bekommt kopfschmerzen
und kreislaufprobleme deswegen solltet
ihr darauf am besten verzichten
tipp nummer vier und dieser typ ist auch
ganz besonders wichtig wenn ihr morgens
etwas erst dann nehmt bitte langkettige
kohlenhydrate zu euch also zum beispiel
kein weissbrodt sondern vollkommen
produkte hafer reis also viele produkte
die euch einfach sättigen und mit viel
ballaststoffe neben angereichert sind
oder eben aus natur von natur aus schon
haben die halten euch lange satt die
geben nämlich dann den zucker zu dem es
dann eben umgewandelt wird langsam an
den körper wieder ab und ihr habt
einfach langfristig ein sättigungsgefühl
und kein hungergefühl
tipp nummer fünf wenn ihr abend von
wieder essen dürft sollte natürlich erst
mal was trinken aber achtet bitte darauf
dass ihr kein kaltes wasser trinkt denn
kaltes wasser auf leeren magen bedeutet
dass ihr magenschmerzen bekommt und vor
allem blähungen
deswegen verzichtet auch morgens in der
regel auch beim frühstück immer auf
kaltes wasser nimmt einfach lauwarmes
wasser oder zimmer warmes wasser
das ist auf jeden fall viel viel besser
tipp nummer sechs bitte erst langsam
wenn ihr abends anfangen zu essen denn
euer sättigungsgefühl kommt ja erst noch
etwa 15 20 minuten und wenn es sehr viel
oder sehr schnell ist es die automatisch
viel denn ihr denkt ihr habt immer noch
hunger
das ist auch allgemeinen problem was wir
haben wir essen alle viel zu schnell
viel zu viel
und später haben wir alle magenschmerzen
bauchschmerzen können uns vor schmerz
kaum erhalten weil es einfach viel zu
viel war deswegen erst langsam taut
lange und ich weiß noch hat abends
hunger möchte viel essen aber gerade auf
leeren magen müsste wirklich darauf
achten dass ihr langsam ist und eben
weniger ist wenn ihr nämlich während der
ramadan zeit auch an gewicht zunimmt
dann macht ihr wirklich was falsch das
heißt dann eigentlich ihr habt so
schnell gegessen automatisch zu viel
gegessen
tipp nummer sieben abends dürft ihr
gerne zuckerhaltige produkte essen weil
die den blutzuckerspiegel schnell wieder
erhöhen
das heißt ihr kommt dann werde dann
wieder fit wieder aktiv und das soll ja
sein da dürfte zuckerhaltiges essen und
trinken am besten zum beispiel auch
datteln humus könnt ihr essen dass es
reicht und das soll einfach den
blutzuckerspiegel wieder erhöht so dass
ihr euch wieder wohlfühlt mein tipp
nummer acht
ihr sollt ihr essen nicht zu sehr wird
weil wenn ihr zu witziges f habt ihr
natürlich danach wieder viel mehr durch
am besten vermeidet ihr auch knoblauch
und so weiter auch wenn es so gut
schmeckt aber knoblauch macht nicht nur
durstig sondern auch einsam stinkend an
und macht einfach diesen ekelhaften
geschmack die ganze zeit im mund und das
ist den tag über wenn man nix essen
nichts trinken darf wirklich sehr
unangenehm
also am ramadan und beim fasten lieber
sehr wenig kürzen und das essen pur
genießen
tipp nummer 911 bitte wenig und sprecht
bitte wenig ihr lacht jetzt
wahrscheinlich darüber
aber wenn ihr beim essen zu viel
sprechen kann es passieren dass er
einfach zu viel luft verschluckt das
heißt dann natürlich auch er bekommt
magenschmerzen und blähungen
ich war es am ramadan ist man gerne in
gesellschaft und spricht auch viel aber
achtet da vielleicht einfach drauf dass
ihr eben nicht während dem essen spricht
oder während des sprechens ja das kann
nämlich bisschen marken schmerzen
verursachen und mein letzter tipp tipp
nummer 10 ernährt euch vitaminreich und
genau an diesen tiefs anknüpfen ihr
könnt nämlich wunderbar morgens und
abends viel obst und viel gemüse zu euch
nehmen
besonders zur fastenzeit ist es ganz
wichtig weil er ja eigentlich den tag
über weniger ist und so eure vitamine
und mineralstoffe zu euch nehmen soll
mein tipp für euch ist wenn er nicht so
wie obst und gemüse faz könnt ihr euch
morgens zum beispiel in 10 remixen
so machen wir das nämlich auch jeden tag
zum frühstück oder eben jetzt zum star
hol
das heißt die zeit vor dem sonnenaufgang
da könnt ihr euch einfach einen smoothie
mixen wissen zum beispiel auch whistler
obst und gemüse sv
deswegen muss ich mir das alles und
trinkt das leber und da könnt ihr
einfach den kühlschrank auf machen und
alles verwenden was ihr wollt ich zeig
euch nämlich jetzt mit einen smoothie
aber das ist jetzt nur so ein tipp von
mir oder so eine variante ihr könnt dann
natürlich alles mögliche nehmen das in
euch keine grenzen gesetzt
ich zeige ich es einfach mal was ich
hier habe hier habe ich zum beispiel im
schälchen himbeeren die waren jetzt tief
gefroren die sind dann schön kalt jetzt
natürlich kalt zucker dürfen sie nicht
sein weil wie gesagt morgens direkt zu
kalt trinken ist nicht so gut
und hier sind natürlich viele vitamine
drin und die in bayern geben
natürlich meinem sowie den leckeren
geschmack einer gemeinschaft hier habe
ich einfach mal so einen obst und gemüse
teller gemacht ich habe hier etwas
salatblätter normalerweise nehme ich
gerne spinat das schmeckt richtig lecker
da denkt jetzt bestimmt jeder ekelhaft
aber spinat schmeckt richtig gut hier
ist natürlich viel wasser drin viel
eisen drin sehr gut für uns ich habe ich
noch eine birne figur könnte sich auch
ein richtiger wasserspender wassermelone
ist immer ganz lecker das mache ich auch
ganz gern rein eine banane und jetzt
schön cremig banane hält natürlich auch
schön satt hier noch eine orange für den
vitamin kiki wie geht auch petersilie
geht auch hat viel viel mehr vitamin c
als alles andere
hier ein paar fische für fans blätter
und natürlich nehmen wir immer gerne
irgendwann das nehmen wir jeden tag zu
uns weil irgendwie einfach so eine
vitamin droge sondern medizin drucke ist
das ist total gut für die verdauung für
den kreislauf für herz fürs blut
eigentlich wirklich für alles ist es so
ein nahrungsmittel zum wunder
nahrungsmittel also das solltet ihr
wirklich immer zu euch nehmen ist auch
total lecker wenn ihr das in seinem
smoothie oder in einem t zum beispiel zu
euch nehmt das ich jetzt also mein
teller und das werde ich jetzt einfach
anders miteinander vermischen
ich habe jetzt einfach einen
durchsichtigen mitte mixa da könnt ihr
auch alles schön zäh aber das geht in
jedem anderen mixa auch aber einen mixer
braucht die auf jeden fall weil sie in
smiths sein soll
ich gebe jetzt einfach alles zusammen
ein und weil wir sehr trinken übergebe
ich noch etwas mineralwasser dazu könnte
aber auch zum beispiel in apfelsaft
nehmen
aber ich möchte jetzt auch nicht zu wild
haben auch nicht zu viel weil es so
schön cremig sein
jetzt wird es einfach schön vermisst
seichte sich probieren kann das geht
amira probieren aber wir kennen das ja
das treffen morgen
wie bitte schön und dann sagen wie es
schmeckt ok als es riecht gut
das hast du doch das ist doch voll
lecker ok man kann da natürlich ein
macht nichts man kann natürlich jedes
obst mit rein machen jedes gemüse ich
würde aber den obst anteil höher halten
an dem gemüseanteil weil es einfach dann
süßer schmeckt und ich wünsche euch auf
jeden fall eine ganz schöne ramadan zeit
ich möchte jetzt unter meinem video
wirklich gar keine religiösen
diskussionen des hirschen koch und back
kanal und falls sich hier wieder ein
paar leute unten streiten weil ich die
kommentare auch löschen
das kommt wirklich eigentlich nie vor
bei mir aber ich sehe es einfach auf
anderen kanälen wo es dann immer ganz
schnell religiös wert und ich möchte
jetzt ganz gern dass ihr aber den
kommentar lasst ihr könnt euch jetzt
gegenseitig oder sollt euch jetzt eine
schöne ramadan zeit wünschen die wünsche
ich euch und uns allen nämlich auch und
ich habe ganz viele tolle rezepte auch
für den ramadan werde ich jetzt ab
morgen alle hochladen und habe mir ganz
vieles ausgedacht und ich wünsche euch
noch einen ganz ganz schönen tag bis
dann papa schon wieder ist aber nett